[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
tonight on Facebook when I sent another
Michael debacle as Harry and Megan jets
in New York remember that Eco Warriors
so they came on a private jet of course
are they getting a human rights award
for trashing their family but is their
Netflix super salt already backfiring
and other environmental activists of the
vegan variety Target steak restaurants
to demand we all eat plant-based gruel
one of them will be here for a meaty
debate
and this former Miss Croatia has been
turning heads and camera lenses the
World Cup in Qatar but is she
disrespecting local culture she'll join
me live to set the record straight
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good evening from
another welcome to Piers Morgan and
sensor tonight Harry and Megan the
world's biggest whiners are accepting a
human rights award yep you heard that
correctly the Duke and Duchess of
Netflix are in New York they flew there
as all environmental Warriors do by
private plane and they're going to be
honored by the Robert F Kennedy
foundation for their heroic fight
against structural racism otherwise they
trash their families call them a bunch
of callous races without producing any
actual evidence well the equality
obsessed environmentalists arrived as I
said by private jet and they're going to
speak at a gala where tickets are
selling for a million dollars each so
that will be after they've preached
about poverty they'll be greeted on
stage by Alec Baldwin the host he you
may remember and spent most of the last
year on a self-pitying tour of
victimhood right up there rally after
shooting dead a female cinematographer
on a film set and maybe facing Chris
criminal charges well Planet Sussex is
an alternative Universe where
self-awareness is an alien concept and
hypocrisy is virtuous the trailers for
their Netflix series have made it clear
the hell bent on attacking the media and
the royal family that they abandoned and
in Britain in the process it's a dirty
game Harry grimly warned it's all about
race said another and as ever there is
Meghan markle's truth and there will be
the truth and despite their
multi-million dollar efforts to rewrite
history all the money and marketing in
the world can't change some basic cold
hard facts remember one of the ghastly
FIB written trailers for their series
featured me
she's becoming a royal rock star
and that part at least is true She was
That's why I said it I meant it at the
time and what it revealed is that far
from being hounded by a racist press in
a country full of rabid racist Megan
haters she was in fact welcomed with
Wide Open Arms not least by the British
media people like me most of the
coverage in Britain and indeed around
the world was extravagantly positive
the future of the royal family will be
shaped by what is now known as The Fab
Four the kind of Royal Beatles Harry
William Megan and Catherine I like Megan
and Harry very much and I do think
they've brought a breath of fresh air
but it represents is the fact that
Society is moving on and that these
boundaries that were in place before are
being lifted we've got Meghan Markle now
we're not going to go anywhere near a
Republic now that we've got the Michael
Sparkle there's something very modern
and forward-looking about about their
love
racist bullying invasive nasty
didn't seem like it did it
look at all those front pages
Harry and Mega's engagement was greeted
with a global gushing of Goodwill as
unified and sincere as anything I've
seen for a generation kisstory said the
front page of our biggest selling
tabloid on the day of their wedding a
historic change for the monarchy one
very excited commentator enthused in
these words a biracial woman from
America marrying into the world's most
famous white family it's hard to
overstate the significance of this
ceremony beamed live around the world to
black people everywhere to borrow the
words of Dr King this was a day when
little black girls could watch TV and
genuinely share little white girls
long-held dreams of one day marrying a
prince and who was the author of that
optimistic and buoyant tribute to the
new biracial British Monarchy it's me
I was just happy as everybody else
Harry and Megan had it all and they got
the press that they deserved before they
got married
they behaved themselves they did the
right thing and we all liked them for it
and in return they got a life of luxury
servants adulation Global superstardom
along with a gigantic privileged
platform for all the causes closest to
their hearts they've got a 30 million
pound wedding
King Charles is about to be torn to
pieces in this documentary series even
walked Megan down the aisle when her
father was too ill to make the trip from
America
they were celebrated second half of the
new Fab Four fated as the Glamorous
energetic future of our monarchy and
then they torched it all and be under No
Illusion they did that to themselves
the Netflix series is their grubbiest
attempt yet to recast themselves as
victims of a brain mob of British bigots
who never wanted Megan here in the first
place
as the late Queen Elizabeth II herself
once said
Recollections may vary
well joining me now is former star of
sasu Des Williams at Middleton organizer
of BLM protests Iman eight well welcome
to both of you
um
and we also sorry down the line we have
real cool spot on the Vanity Fair okay
I'll stop with Katie nickel um Casey
thanks for joining me
I gotta say the nearer we get to This
Global event as Netflix call it which is
going to be Unleashed on Thursday
morning at 8am with the first three
episodes the more angry I'm becoming
about what this is going to do to a
grieving Monarch who's not even been
coronated yet to replace his mother to
the new Prince of Wales trying to build
that position now for himself and his
wife and his children uh all of it makes
me puke that these two once again are
going to be reigning muck all over their
families not just for the global
titillation but for hard dollars 80
million dollars which is why they're
doing it
absolutely and I can only imagine for
the king for the Prince of Wales I mean
they must just have their heads in their
hands
um exasperated frustrated hurt betrayed
angry all words that I've been told are
the feelings behind closed doors at the
palace um you know who knows whether
they're going to be tuning in when the
first three episodes of this docu-series
drop on Thursday I suspect the Royal
lawyers will be watching very closely
I'm sure the courtiers will be watching
closely particularly those who claim
they were bullied by Megan The Duchess
of Sussex and I think the problem with
all of this is is so clearly highlighted
in those very controversial trailers is
it is so partisan it is so one-sided and
I suspect will come away saying exactly
what we said after the Oprah interview
well where were the counter questions
where you know where are the Tabloid
editors who can put another side of the
argument across they say they want to
put across their truth but is it the
truth well we know after Oprah's nowhere
near the truth
um at Middleton you've always been very
supportive of Harry I think the military
connection obviously and there's no
doubt you know this this guy served his
country with honor
um in war zones and he deserves great
credit for that my brother-in-law taught
him at Santos Military Academy said he
was a fine young Soldier nothing could
take that away from him uh but what I've
I detect from people I know in the
military is unbelievable disappointment
in what he's now becoming and the fact
that of course when you've served the
military you serve them oath to you know
serve your country and your Monarch yes
and here he is just now constantly
attacking his father who's the new king
and the monarchy the institution I think
when people are fed up with being
suffocated by wokeness and by a uh you
know an attention-seeking manner like
they they have been
um you can't defend them anymore you
know Harry I defended him all along said
look he's protected his country served
his country he should go off like they
wanted to go off and live their life
outside of the media outside the
Limelight privacy media and I completely
respected that I thought to myself you
know what the man served this country
let him get away they didn't mean to but
to then do the complete opposite not the
complete opposite discreetly the
complete opposite in the face in our
faces not only the people of our of his
country which we we did look at him as
our Prince but also the monarchy you
know I serve the monarchy I swore
Allegiance yeah you know I fought for
Harry for William for the queen for the
king I fought for those people
um during you know during a couple of
decades so when I see now that I've not
only defended them but he's come out and
the wokeness behind it the virtual
signaling behind this is is sickening
now people I think people have got to
the point where they're they're fed up
with hearing the same old but also and
then making money out of it well it's
also it's also hypocrisy and lies right
in the two trailers which last no more
than two and a half minutes between them
already six of the images that they have
used in the trailers to illustrate the
intrusion into their lives have been
proven to be the complete opposite
either they weren't at the events which
are being depicted like one's a Harry
Potter Premiere five years before they
met or their official photo calls or the
pictures they've used were actually from
people who'd been officially approved to
stand there and take those pictures of
the Royals to promote them what's very
obvious in here peers what's very
obvious here is there's a there's a
there's a toxic partner in this
relationship and we know who it is you
know Harry is not the person that he is
now when you look at the two differences
of what's inside
it's going to finish on one point about
the lying is one thing the hypocrisy
these two go on about carbon footprint
about the environment and where do they
wash up to get this award in another
private plane I mean to me again they
say one thing they preach one thing but
they do the complete opposite right the
stage is yours thank you just give me
one good reason why we shouldn't be
feeling this way about these okay you
know what I'm going to start with the
first point because I've had to listen
to a load of people vilify this woman
all day every day and you know what I'm
fed up with it so first points okay so
the commercialization of the rift within
the royal family is a byproduct okay a
byproduct of the institution's failure
to be anti-racist and Cooperative which
is ultimately led to a series of Savvy
business skills and strategic Maneuvers
on their parts in order to ensure or the
Safety and Security of their family what
you both fail to understand secondly
institutionalized racism when pertaining
to institutionalized racism when an
individual needs help try to seek help
and realize that there is no one to turn
to what you'll often find and you should
know this as a journalist what you often
find is that person will seek solace in
the media and press hold on a second
hold on in an attempt to Garner support
build awareness understanding and
Inspire action and all of these typical
circumstances would be perfectly okay
but for some reason it's not but we
don't disagree with that we don't
disagree with that any normal
circumstances hold on a second it's not
for this particular couple now hold on
let's just bear that in mind I want to
ask you one thing about what you just
said okay where is the evidence that she
went to people at the palace and they
refused to give her help who were these
people nearly two years later we still
don't have any names okay nothing right
now we're holding on to the fact that
she won't give names and I've already
told you that I think she's a liar hold
on a second right I think she's a bad
face saying that she's alive yes but
right so let me just say this firstly
she said her son
she said well I'm going to say why I
call her a liar she said to Oprah
Winfrey her son had not been made a
prince because of his skin color
absolute line okay so that this is what
okay by virtue of the fact that you've
come out with that uh opinion or thought
it shows me that you have a very
rudimentary understanding of racism so
let me break it down to both of you hold
on a second no hold on a second hold on
a second no no no no no tell me about
racism Okay the reason why institutions
are able to perpetuate racism is because
they rely heavily on Covert racism which
is hard to prove therefore it thrives
let me just break it down some more
because you clearly don't understand
covert racism is racial Prejudice that
is subtle and discreet and often uh
despised and rationalized with an
alternative explanation
I saw that openly I would jump in I
would say
100 I think any normal what do you mean
that's not right that's not right racism
full stop it should be Stamped Out
absolutely but you don't even understand
it
but I do understand you don't understand
one thing
perpetuated
but you're getting into the nitty-gritty
of things now what nitty-gritty
questions
excuse me
my show your show here's my point my
point about Megan and Harry they say all
this stuff without producing any
evidence and you wouldn't to support it
but you wouldn't let me finish I've
already just explained to you covert
racism is racial Prejudice that is uh uh
subtle and discreet hold on a second no
but this
isn't made a difference
let me explain this is what I'm trying
to explain to you then you won't let me
finish so let me finish you'll be able
to raise your point okay okay so
racial prejudice
that is subtle and discrete called
covert racism hold on listen just
listening
because the reality is I can give you an
example because clearly you're not
getting it so someone can come along and
say oh I don't like Megan because she's
this she's that she's a lie she's this
she's that when the reality is secretly
it's actually hold on a second let me
finish this and it's actually due to the
fact that Harry who is a royal ended up
marrying a woman from the black
community but you cannot say that out
loud because that has got nothing to do
with oh it is
calm down calm down listen because you
won't listen your way through the next
hour right here's my point about that
nothing I've ever said that's critical
of Meghan Markle has anything to do with
her skin color okay perfect so at best
either subliminal or overt or any other
way is to do with her hypocrisy and her
life hypocrisy because ultimately
also think she's a fake let me ask you
one question front page of every paper
today well most of them have pictures of
her crying in the trailer for the series
do you think those tears were genuine
okay so this is what I'm not even going
to go down there well the journeys are
trying to lead on the fact that just
because someone is an actress that they
I'm asking you do you think Brian you
are implying I do because the reality is
ultimately said that I want to play you
something I want to tell you something
so this is an actress who can
you
can
question
this is Meghan Markle
oh my God it's crazy
one tier lest I go give me three seconds
[Music]
three seconds is all it takes ready to
cry and just a quick one on on that
piece he's an
actresses
in the cold this is how
institutionalized racism works when you
dare to go up to against an institution
due to the fact that they're
perpetuating racial Prejudice
you're trying to pretend that it's
something do you not think people use
that card as well and they're vindictive
manipulative
yeah look at the front pages there which
is when their engagement was announced
yeah where's the racism
do you remember that was before she
actually said that the institution was
racist and that's my point how
institutionalized racism works is the
military
institutions sorry for just every one of
chanting that's what happens you accept
there's no racism in those media Pages
because that was before she said that
the institution was racist actually
that's when everyone decided to Pilot
actually what happened as a woman people
began to pile on when she started having
half a million dollar baby showers in
New York and flying back on the Clooney
private plane they started having a
pylon started having a pile on when they
used Elton John's private plane like a
taxi rank whilst preaching about carbon
footprint they had another pile on where
they had other huge extravagant events
they went to and then when they're
preaching about poverty on their Twitter
account time and again they were caught
being rankly hypocritical that was why
the media coverage began to turn then
there was all the stuff with her father
many people felt that she was
unnecessarily cruel to her father people
have since criticized his own behavior I
accept that but certainly to start with
they ditched him they dropped him
Harry's never met his his father-in-law
in his life
you know he proposed marriage to this
girl knowing what's going to happen and
then doesn't do anything to protect the
father at all and so now she's disowned
him what kind of people but compassion
on their website as they do as being at
the center of their core being when they
live 70 miles away from this guy who has
not got long for this world is in poor
health all he wants to do is meet his
grandchildren and she won't have
anything to do with him that's not
compassionate
and also the hypocrisy and the lies are
not what I think are decent values in
people sorry all of those things seem to
outweigh the fact that a black woman is
nothing to do with everything is about
racism she is ultimately turned around
and said that that institution is racist
and everyone has decided to pile on so
let me just tell you in terms of my
thoughts at best these individuals are
weak insecure hate to see a rift and
have a positive Prejudice towards a
royal family and at worst they are a
bunch of disgusting racists who fail to
acknowledge their racial Prejudice and
actually find solace in seeking
self-esteem and status from gases either
one or the other problem here's the
problem here's the problem I would have
said exactly the same thing if she'd
been White
exactly the same thing what's the point
that you're trying and actually Kate
Middleton who came in she got criticized
very heavily by the media early on in
that relationship and she just did her
Duty accepted in return for all the
luxury racism these two different
contend with racism though where did the
racism come from okay so you're clearly
not understanding no you're not
understanding me where did the racism
come from tell me who was racist and
when okay I'm going to answer for you
okay who and when right let's just start
with everyone who and when okay so let
me answer okay firstly racism as I've
said over the last several years and
I'll say it again racism is firmly
interwoven into the fabric of British
Society due to its historical context
and that wasn't my question and that way
I'm answering your questions that's my
question let me finish who was racist to
Megan and Harry in the British media who
was racist at the palace and when were
they racist can I answer your question
now sure give me one example perfect so
firmly racism is family interwoven into
the fabric of British Society
secondly I'm going to make my point I'm
going to make an example hold on a
second secondly the royal family smeared
their own name tarnished their own name
by failing to adopt anti-racism
and they've perpetuated I only want one
example I'm giving you the example of
the British media being racist or
someone in the palace an example let me
finish please is that okay Pierce thank
you very much so I can answer the
question I'm going to answer the
question so in terms of the institution
I'm going to give you several examples
of covert racism clearly as you don't
understand first
I'm going to I do but I see the flip
side as well
badges
I'm giving you examples but you won't
let me see give me one specific example
I'm giving you examples all right so in
terms of media because this is what
happens with you you're clearly not
trying to hear me just ask for a fact in
terms of the media we've already seen
the clear distinction between how the
media has uh displayed or or spoken or
represented obviously in terms of how
they've represented yes they do in terms
of uh carry or holding a baby someone
I'm sorry Kate held her stomach and
therefore it was fine then can held her
stomach and she's a terrible person
racism that's called covert racism that
you don't understand oh it's nonsense
there is no racism
you can continue to perpetuate your
covert racism
I have to leave it there we've had a
good run at this hey I don't have any
racism covert or over no you have racial
Prejudice I have no racial Prejudice
racist whatsoever I have none whatsoever
that's what you don't understand I won't
be giving you 21 minutes of my show so
because on a regular basis about a
racial Prejudice what happened so you
white people tend to justify either
sleeping with a black person having a
black friend into hiring a black person
as to uh
if you can provide some facts behind
which I did extremely excited yes which
I can't say everyone's racist in Britain
but I can't give you a single example
she already experienced Lisa institution
I already told you that woman just I
know I'm a gaslighting covert racist
thank you very much you are indeed all
right great to see you thank you uh well
after the break uh waitress is doing
what so many authorities have failed to
do getting stuck into the Eco Warriors
I'll talk to animal Rebellion uh man
there he is uh that we got in there uh
you took part in this protest at a state
restaurant in London their spokesman
Nathan McGovern a celebrity chef
although zilly will be thinking my teeth
into his meaty debate next
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
tonight we're on here in five minutes
yeah I'm just getting some stress fine
same amount of dice
guitar for me okay you're definitely out
there right yeah yeah I need some
a-listers on the show how we're getting
5 000 quick
Stadium
go back into football but I can't speak
Portuguese I'd probably be able to get a
beer out here I can great okay
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
Miss Croatia on why she should be able
to wear whatever she wants or is it
unless she wants it appears in Qatar
we'll debate that shortly there she is
live and oh a little overdressed perhaps
can't hear us but that may not be a
problem but first vegan activists are
not giving up their quest to make us all
the Bland plant-based gruel they've
tipped milk all over the floor of
fortnum and Mason and salvages in London
they've heard white paint at the gates
of the houses of Parliament now they've
targeted a high-end Steakhouse in London
and the waitresses did what many have
wanted to do with these protesters for a
while take a look
thank you for the market tonight
well joining me uh now is animal
Rebellion spokesman Nathan McGovern and
somebody Chef Aldo zilli got it right
this time he picked me up but it's Aldo
not old Aldo's a very British
pronunciation in Italian uh good to see
you both uh Nathan start with you
um I I don't like vegans very much I
don't think any of you are very healthy
I'm not surprised by that yeah I think
you all look pretty face to face and
unhealthy to me um but that's your
choice what I don't do is I don't go
running into vegan restaurants and start
screaming abuse at you all and have to
be pulled out by people because you're
ruining everyone's fun why do you do
that to meat eaters
well peers you've started on an absolute
blind today I actually brought a little
game with me for the me Aldo perhaps the
audience to play it sir Piers Morgan a
vegan Bingo maybe we could zoom on that
from the camera and you've actually just
ticked off wanna straight away I'll just
go with that with looking at row or a
column already so the thing is
within years
technology like Precision fermentation
you know old protein is going to produce
the exact same products that you love
right now using a fraction of the land
producing a fraction what did you mean
it's the exact same product no but I
like utme fine you know you'll be eating
the exact same product
the more the more meat I want to eat
that's absolutely fine it is that's fine
literally it's a bit honestly it's true
the more stuff you do like this right I
think I didn't catch that it's true is
it you've said that about three times I
didn't touch it that you like you meet
yes oh oh thanks I didn't get it the
first three times I'm how committed to
vegan are you how committed a vegan
aren't I would you eat do you drink
almond milk oh you've ticked off another
one fantastic
they're answering questions I don't know
I'll keep that one hidden from you
just answer questions otherwise there's
not much of an interview I mean you can
have your little child but do you drink
almond milk no do you eat almonds no you
eat avocados
no what'd you eat what do you drink I
love seasonal British fruit and veg
right you know I love supporting British
Farmers I love going to a farmer's
market seeing what they have to offer
you know I love eating a plant-based
most science now says that if you don't
have a balanced diet it's actually
unhealthy for you yeah exactly that's
why a plant-based diet a balanced
plant-based diet is healthy I'll do but
we what do you feel I mean your
restaurant is very close to where this
happened right what do you feel about
these activists running in ruining
people's meals
listen
um 25 years ago I opened one of the
first vegetarian restaurants in London
in SoHo and if it was now it's probably
more successful today and it didn't get
very successful but anyway come cut long
story short
I don't have any problems I've ridden a
vegetarian book not a vegan book
I don't have any problems with vegan and
veganism and vegetarian people because I
have restaurants I'm a consultant for a
number of restaurants number of
restaurant companies and we have vegan
and vegetarians on menus so I don't
understand
when it gets out of hand
that these people have to well they
disrupt our business because they have
no respect for meat eaters uh but if we
were doing the same thing to them they'd
all go nuts right wouldn't you you'll go
nuts if I came running into your little
vegan hell holes and began screaming
abuse you'd all throw your toys out the
brown as you do on a daily basis
I'm gonna throw my toys out the pram
right now peers I'm loving this to be
honest what are you loving I'm loving it
this open conversation that we're having
about it's actually quite but why did
you have to go and and do a restaurant
and disrupt our business disrupt the
customers other people that want to eat
the meat other people that want to enjoy
themselves so they want to go out and
have a night out I don't have any
problems you guys coming to our
restaurants and ordering a vegan dish in
fact in January we always do a vegan
worry and we got through a lot of
different
ingredients to create menus for you guys
I don't understand why we have to suffer
your mentality of coming to our
restaurants and trying to disrupt the
customers that are having a fantastic
time and they want to eat the steak
what's the answer no it's actually a
good question and actually it's
fantastic that you create fantastic
vegan dishes the fact of the matter is
when we look at high-end restaurants you
know salt-based restaurant Manor up in
Manchester that was also disrupted the
weekend these are symbols of a broken
system you know because he makes nice
symbols of a broken system where you
know there's 1500 quid yeah why is he
making millions no please around the
world I was in one of his restaurants
last week in Qatar I loved it fantastic
but he served me they're always waiting
for you to show it so I was wondering
how long it would take it's me doing his
little uh salt trick he talks you
weren't very good at it even actually
flunked it in front of me affect me
actually directly fed me the meat into
my mouth it was delicious loved it
if you'd run in and tried to interrupt
and just ruin everyone's night I would
have done what those were interested to
just thrown you out that's absolutely
fine so what's the point of view what
does it achieve none of you make me want
to change my mind I just think what
annoying little squids honestly I do
it's the same when you're chucking paint
at Van Gogh's paintings it's the same
when you're tying yourself to fuel pumps
or hanging yourself on Bridges and
stopping people using Dart of a tunnel
it's all the same you're just all too
annoying so the British public don't
like annoying people and they don't like
their lives being disrupted they want
their freedom to have a choice the
choices I had in Qatar last week to have
sold but whose restaurant you made you
to do this to my mouth can you imagine
someone coming in
your evening have you got the clip
we haven't got the claim ah wash oh he's
running okay no but can you imagine you
coming to our restaurants and and then
you get some people coming to your table
and trying to disrupt your evening it's
a it's abuse I'm gonna start Ryan I'm
going to start running into vegan
restaurants
and so you can't eat your gruel and just
see how you look like it I'm gonna go to
your house and Shop paint all over it
yes
you've got a right to price oh you've
got me another one big enough
but where's the salt where's where's it
I don't need any of this gruel yeah to
one side but I will have a bit of steak
just to you didn't salt it though you
see all you've achieved is you've made
me want to do this just absolutely
absolutely fine
you go for it
[Music]
do you know do you know how many steaks
he's had from my restaurant yeah a lot a
lot a lot but here's my point
I love eating steak I'm not going to
stop eating steak Yeah and the the very
last thing on Earth that we'll stop
eating steak is people like you with
your pasty faces running into our
restaurants telling us to stop eating
steak that's the very last thing
absolutely because you don't represent a
mean Vitality or good health you just
want to let you want a good bit of steak
that's absolutely fine you're fully
entitled to that opinion and as I've
just said earlier you're right to
protest if you want to run it your mates
are also the extinction Rebellion right
my mates you're all like interwoven like
you said before we came on like a like a
wool and blanket are you connected or
not no no so we're a sister movement
assistant what's that sounds a bit sexy
we have you know Common goals you know
irritating people
such as tackling the climate and
ecological emergencies which you know
I'm sure all of us what did you think of
Megan and Harry using a private plane oh
there we go Meghan Markle that's another
one four for nine now I'm not going to
give you that what did you think of them
using a private plane to go to this uh
awards show
you must be feared it's incredible how
you manage are you feeling to turn this
into oh let's dump on Megan your agenda
appears oh
I just wonder whether you're not in
their plane I just wonder whether you
think do you feel do you feel angry they
used a private plane or not
what we should have is Affordable Travel
for everyone but they they used what we
should have is Travel Systems do you
criticize something
you know or because there's a working
company
I would have much preferred you know why
you can't don't you know thing because
this is again hypocrisy
you don't want to read a headline
tomorrow saying Nathan McGovern from
animal Rebellion slams Megan and Harry
for using private plane you don't want
to say it because like them you're a
flaming hypocrite you're rather go in
there we go you've got me a column you'd
rather go past it you'd rather go into
restaurants like Aldos or salt Bays or
whatever and just make a nuisance of
your cells because it's easier but what
you should be doing for intellectually
honest and say Megan and Harry stop
using private plans but you won't yeah
because I will say it right now I will
say it right now final was you about a
balanced diet most science I've read
lately says that actually having no meat
in your data tool is not necessarily A
beneficial official for that matter
right or fish yeah I mean we have to
have a balanced diet and we it's
important for our well-being for getting
healthy if you work out in the gym like
I do I need to have maybe some good
protein yeah and if I if I don't I I did
go vegan for six months
um a couple of years ago
I went vegan for an hour I had a lettuce
it didn't kill me it didn't give up what
about that vegan Greg sausage roll it
was disgusting complete exactly more
calories in a Greg's vegan sausage roll
than there are in a McDonald's
cheeseburgers
at least it tastes better it's naming
the dishes and you know the like the
if you want to win an argument you just
can't be annoying all the time you can't
just ruin everyone's fun and their lives
walking around like you have the only
way forward for the life in the universe
the Nathan McGovern rule book it's not
me Thou shalt do this this and this
unless the American and Harry then you
can do that University it's the ipcc
this isn't me I'm not a scientist right
I'm perfect I think we'll leave it
people from the University university of
Harvard you're not nice to see neither
are you and you should listen to you're
not an expert I think we'll leave it at
that Nathan
sorry we didn't get them all together
insects yeah
um good to see you both thank you Alden
great to see you great good to see you
Nathan happy irritant uh next to know
she's been ogled a photograph of the
World Cup in Qatar but some have accused
of disrespecting local culture the form
of restoration Ivana Noel thinks she
should better wear whatever she likes
she'll join me next alongside a
disapproving Qatari businessman
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
mate we're on here in five minutes yeah
I'm just getting with some stress fine
same allosis you've got someone at
guitar for me okay you're definitely out
there right yeah yeah I'm out here I
need some a-listers on the show how it's
getting 5 000 quick
Stadium
go back into football but I can't speak
Portuguese I'd probably be able to get a
beer out here I can great okay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Phelps on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
well you may have seen my next guest
standing out from the crowds at
Croatia's World Cup match she's just
about dressed in her country's famous
red and white checkable colors her
outfits have certainly attracted the
attention to many including local
qataris but should form a Miss Croatia
Ivana Canal dubbed the World Cup's
sexiest fan by the media respect the
culture of Qatar while she's in the
country well I'm joined Now by former
Miss Croatia Ivana canal and by Muhammad
Hassan al-jaferi who believes that women
should dress modestly in Qatar and
tweeted her to that effect well welcome
to both of you let me start with you if
I may uh Ivana you've obviously got a
lot of attention there as you did indeed
at the Russia World Cup and the Brazil
World Cup it's something you enjoy doing
and obviously no problem doing it
somewhere like Brazil but have you
encountered any resistance or opposition
to you doing it in Qatar
can you hear me Ivana
yes hi Pierce I hear you oh thank
goodness I was worried we'd lost you so
let me ask you that I'll ask you again
um have you had any people criticizing
you to your face in Qatar for your
clothing
uh now to be honest I'm very surprised
and very happy that they accept my
closing and many Arab Qatar people came
to do photos with me even female males
kids and everyone and it's really nice
to see us doing your photos I mean it's
one thing doing it in Brazil as you did
in the 2014 uh World Cup but obviously
there is a more conservative dress code
in Qatar I was there last week and you
know some local qataris certainly
including our other guests tonight would
have thought that it might have been
better for you to respect the culture by
wearing more clothes what do you say to
that
um I didn't have any bad reactions to be
honest and I was very happy about that
because they accept us because many
people are here from the other countries
and I was so happy because nothing
happened and I didn't have any bad
reactions not even one very interesting
well let's let's go to Mohammed Hassan
al-jaferi York tari local and you
tweeted just for your info they take a
photo not because they like her talking
about Ivana but because they don't like
the way she's mistressed in regards to
our culture you can confirm this with
any local Qatari probably to report it
so Muhammad thank you for joining me so
you weren't impressed by what Ivana was
wearing
um I mean do you find it offensive or
what is your position
actually I would go a neuter because I
have seen a lot of similar way clothing
in Qatar but many people are reporting
this in WhatsApp and sending messages
and sending these kind of different
videos and photos for some uh non-clear
uh people like so for example similar to
the way she wire addressed we see it
like it's really so strange to be here
in Qatar wearing like that so we've seen
the dress code of FIFA stadiums and at
tournaments and maybe some people
reported these kind of things and maybe
she didn't know about that so I thought
it's a very good chance to also invite
her to know more about the other
perspective from the side of people who
maybe don't agree with her but yeah you
wouldn't find people who will come to
you and say that in front of you or
front of your face or something like
that that's common because we've been
used to have a lot of guests and Qatar
now for the past like maybe 15 years we
have it's a multinational country so you
can see
all different kinds of nationality and
I'm sure that you experience okay well
let me let me ask Ivana I mean maybe
it's a good chance as well to to invite
her to to try our Abaya it's really nice
and I think it's going to be really good
on her well I think the point I think
you've made Ivana I think I read you
saying uh elsewhere is that there are no
restrictions in Croatia on what people
can wear including if people want to
wear Muslim garments that's obviously
completely fine and tolerated so your
position I think I don't want to speak
for you is that why shouldn't you be
allowed to wear what you want to wear
when you're in Qatar
I I respect every country where I'm
coming and I asked about the rules here
and locals confirmed me that I can
address as usually because for the World
Cup they are making an exceptions uh and
they will allow us to wear on the way
how we are wearing it unusually and
that's why I decided to wear my outfits
because uh locals confirm me that it's
allowed and I didn't have any bad
reaction as I told you katari people
Arabic people coming to me to do uh
photos with me even very nice female and
woman's on the stadium on the last game
they came the photo went also viral with
a nice hijab and they came to me to do
photos with me in my outfit creation
outfit what I had uh in the last game
and I think that's amazing to accepting
each other to be different I think
that's actually a perfectly fine
response and Mohammed I think I
appreciate the fact that you've not been
too confrontational you I think there's
a mutual respect here and maybe some
work to be done perhaps in how you both
view each other and the cultural
differences but I I'm glad we brought
you both together and it's been an
interesting debate thank you both very
much indeed for joining me
thanks
well after the break with ambulance
workers nurses and train workers all set
to strike and they're on after Christmas
are unions losing public support
depending that with my pack next don't
go away
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
tonight we're on here in five minutes
yeah I'm just getting ready
you've got someone at the top of me okay
you're definitely out there right yeah
yeah I'm out here so I need some
a-listers on the show yeah we're just
getting 5000 quick
Stadium
but I can't speak Portuguese I'd
probably be able to get a beer out here
I can
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Phelps on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to business let's just take
uh well let's talk to tonight's pack
talk TV contributor original tires Laura
and commentator Paula Ron Asia welcome
to both it's been a lively old show
let's have a bit of a bit of calm and
talk about the union shall we
um Richard's eyes I always have a sort
of instinctive feeling in tough times
like this that most public sector
workers probably do get a pretty unfair
rub of the green actually but when
you've got inflation raging at the
levels that it's raging you just can't
give everybody what they want without
the country literally Keeling over what
do we do about this sort of onpass where
the unions are getting more militant
more aggressive wrecking Christmas by
the look of it
um I'm gonna see nurses go out ambulance
workers plus no trains and so on what's
the solution here well everybody knows
that if you if you lift their salaries
by the rate of inflation or more
inflation goes up and up it's a
never-ending Circle we ended up back in
the 70s that is not the way to go what
you should actually be doing is cutting
their taxes that is less inflationary
and it's the way to solve this the
Tories don't understand that at all
they're trying to be dogmatic I don't
know where this goes but it may end up
here's in a situation where basically
the Tories lose the ability to govern in
the first quarter of next year we could
end up with an early earlier general
election and maybe that's actually the
agenda of some of the Hardline unions
Paula I mean is it you know regardless
of anyone's individual politics does the
country need perhaps a fresh pair of
eyes I mean is it it feels to me this
conservative party it's not Richie's Sue
Knoxville he's inherited this Basket
Case really but it seems to me we're in
that sort of last moments of John Majors
tenure when everyone was just fed up and
it's like let's just you know what let's
just try something else yeah because I
don't think labor have all the answers
it would be a very difficult challenge
for Kia stammer and his team but you
sort of feel like we're heading that way
and that in a way this might be as
Richard said the Tipping Point I mean
completely and I have to say say that
we're actually going to agree tonight
because this isn't but this isn't just
about a pay increase okay it's about a
quality of life that no longer exists
anymore and it's about being able to
achieve that quality of life and we
don't have to achieve that quality of
life just through our wage we can get
parking back for nurses we can get the
staff recruited we can get retention
dealt with it's those types it seems to
me unbelievable Richard that we live in
a country where nurses have to pay for
the right to park outside it's about
hospitals where they save people's lives
and then they all get parking tickets
it's absurd I put afford a fully costed
plan yesterday to retain and attract not
only Healthcare staff but actually
social care stuff I would actually give
them zero basic record income tax for
three years and you fund it by not
paying the bank of England paying huge
amounts of money on its QE debt which is
just absurd which is enriching City
banks at the expense of the tax person
should we is one of the problems we had
we had of
courseman the Home Secretary who didn't
know what her own Rwanda policy was and
today we have Michelle uh Donald who is
uh the culture secretary who was asked a
simple question today in a committee
can you name Scotland's culture
secretary I'll drop that off my head
Angus Robertson
he is your he is your opposite number
in Edinburgh
um
and she didn't even know her own
opposite number this is a senior Cabinet
member she was refreshing refreshingly
honest about being stupid
no she had no choice Christian's an
embarrassing corner but then in reality
let's remember the SMP are literally
trying to destroy the culture of the
United Kingdom by separating even more
reasons
yeah before we let you go tonight your
other half has written this book The
Matt Hancock Diaries in which he seems
to blame everybody but himself for
everything what's your take on it
honestly because my take is a riveting
read so Isabel but in terms in terms of
him is two years ago to the day since he
came on Good Morning Britain and cried
here yes without apparently any evidence
of Tears take a look simple words there
reacting it you're quite emotional by
that well it's just it's been
you know it's been such a tough year for
so many people
and he wins the Mega Market award there
I mean he clearly doesn't does he
because I don't see any tears there
there is arrogance his refusal to admit
they've got any mistakes particularly in
the early days he's utterly infuriate
yeah and look there are some things that
wasn't his fault but there's some
serious things coming out of this now
about the mask wearing the lack of
Investigation about whether or not to
close schools there's a lot more to come
out I want to end on a happy note
tonight because we had a lot of shouting
Neil Diamond five years ago got
diagnosed with Parkinson's and last
night on Broadway they launched a
musical version of Neil Diamond and he
turned up and at the end he did this
[Music]
fabulous that means a man with
Parkinson's five years after diagnosis
brought the house down it was beautiful
absolutely beautiful and and in my house
I'm sure in many houses across the
United Kingdom whenever that song is
played you know you have well we know
when it might be played on Saturday
night against France fingers crossed if
we can somehow repel and as I speak
Portugal I think I've just hammered five
or six in their game so they learn
dangerous too thanks to my pack keep it
up uncensor whatever you're up to uh
good night
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you